au dessus deux autres candidats à savoir
donc julien berthet et ilona dénonce
l'effet de ilan en disant qu' il a pris
plusieurs fois défi à leur insu venus et
les a renvoyés et également il parle de
viol donc interdit de parler du violeur
dans le groupe certains candidats
carrément menace la production de
quitter le tournage silane à paris et je
me dis qu'au final combat en effet ils
ou elles n'ont pas fait apparaître dans
le cross mais se retrouve mis en avant
dans une télé juste derrière donc six
ans dans deux jours je mets princes et
les princesses de ça sera dans les
principes princesse de l'amour d'or donc
dans quelques jours alors bien sûr ces
propos n'engagent que vous un bien sûr
la nature et alix que nous on a ou n'a
pas vu il est ou non moi personnellement
j'ai nommé personne j'ai
la ville si je me permets de parler
ainsi c'est que vous êtes sûr de vous je
suis sûr de moi et que j'ai pigé
certaines choses on a vu qu'on avait
vous avez mis certaines preuves sur les
réseaux notamment d'aider des
screenshots de conversation ou whatsapp
vous aujourd'hui vous avez voulu vous
aviez voulu dénoncer l' affaire pourquoi
parce que pour faire du buzz ou parce
que ça la vidéo vraiment vous a choqué
alors
pour faire du buzz aujourd'hui quand je
parle et quand je traite un sujet bien
sûr votre métier c'est mon métier ça
fait du buzz et c'est comme ça que je
vis aujourd'hui
maintenant j'essaye de dénoncer je
pourrais dénoncer tout un tas de choses
j'essaie de dénoncer des faits de
société des faits qui concerne tout le
monde et qui peuvent aider le problème
est que ces personnalités aujourd'hui
que je dénonce elle génère beaucoup
d'argent et forcément
ça ça repose sur leur image et quand
quelqu'un vient et annonce de telles
choses et c'est de dénoncer et de et de
montrer le vrai visage de certaines
personnes bah ça dérange parce que du
coup on fait perdre de l'argent et on
cherche à les faire taire à tout prix
quitte à envoyer des gens chez eux bon
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure de faire
sauter les réseaux c'est une chose même
si même si aujourd'hui ça me pèse
puisque ça m'empêche de faire sauter vos
réseaux vous êtes travail tout à fait
c'est à dire que je vis sur mes réserves
heureusement c'est un métier aujourd'hui
qui rapporte très bien mais mais c'est
vrai je suis très embêtant nabil qu'est
ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé parce que
vous avez suivi de grosses pressions
paraît que vous avez été menacée à tout
à la suite de quoi la suite de cette
vidéo ensuite des informations que vous
avez donnée il ya trois mois de ça quand
quand j'ai voulu le dénoncer donc j'ai
parlé de photos de nude envoyé de
certaines filles prises à leur insu j'ai
également parlé d'une fille mineure
d'une petite rockeuse de 16 ans et donc
suite à sa ilan m'a contacté et m'a
clairement menacée l'an il a deux c'est
le
la personne présumée c'est la vidéo pour
ça et donc il vous a contacté je dis
quoi
il m'a menacé m'a demandé de retirer et
puis m'a envoyé un message en disant je
vais t'envoyer je vais pas citer le
prénom mais il m'a sorti un prix non il
va te les batteux truc est amer donc
l'image haut niveau chine voilà le
message a été supprimé mais on voit ma
réponse juste après je lui dis en bois
qui tu veux de toute façon je n'ai peur
que de dieu chose que je ne savais pas
et je n'ai pas vu enfin je n'ai pas fait
le lien en tout de suite trois semaines
après en effet j'ai reçu la visite de
quelqu'un chez moi qui m'attendait
depuis déjà un bon moment j'ai eu très
très peur qu'est ce que la personne est
venue vers vous et vous vous aimez la
série doit tout à fait clairement j'ai
été menacé on m'a dit que si je repars
l'aide gillan la prochaine de la
prochaine visite se passerait beaucoup
moins bien on a clairement menacé mais
proche de 6 donc j'ai déménagé à cause
de ça aujourd'hui via dubaï cc c'est
tout récent d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
vous avez déménagé de oui oui cause des
deux pins suis trop de menaces disons
que je pense pour être honnête je
pensais déjà à y aller mais ça vachement
accélérer le le processus sachant que
c'est pas la première fois blanc de l'an
dernier je me suis retrouvé à cause
d'une affaire des réseaux sociaux dans
un coffre dont j'étais en booking sur
paris point b d'ailleurs juste parce que
connaissent les relations je connais
très bien fait on
savait que je connais très bien pauvre
il aura envoyé là bas donc j'étais là
bas pour une prestation donc pour faire
de la pub et on m'a envoyé quatre
armoires à glace et oui j'ai fini dans
un coffre et on m'a demandé de faire une
story en m'excusant et en disant que
j'avais manqué